[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen guten
Abend mit mir im Studio für den Sport
ist Norbert König guten Abend dann
verschaffen wir uns jetzt einen
gemeinsamen
Überblick Schlagabtausche im Bundestag
nach langem Ringen in der Ampelkoalition
soll der Haushalt
2024 diese Woche verabschiedet
werden jetzt auch an Flughäfen mit
bundesweiten Warnstreiks kämpfen
Gewerkschaften in mehreren Branchen für
bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen und Spielideen für
Jung und Alt die weltgrößte
Spielwarenmesse in Nürnberg setzt dieses
Jahr noch mehr auf
Erwachsene wir starten in die Sendung
mit rund
477 Milliarden Euro das die Summe die
die ampelregierung in diesem Jahr
ausgeben möchte und über die heute im
Bundestag beraten wurde ursprünglich war
der Plan der Bundesregierung ein anderer
wurde aber vom Bundesverfassungsgericht
durchkreuzt so dass dann gespart und neu
gerechnet werden musste dazu gab es
laute Kritik im Bundestag die hören wir
gleich zuvor erklärt Thomas gonsor wofür
das meiste Geld ausgegeben
wird der Bund will in diesem Jahr
insgesamt
476,8 Milliarden Euro ausgeben größter
Posten soziales
175,6 Milliarden gut 9 Milliarden mehr
als vergangenes Jahr große Teile gehen
an die Rentenversicherung und das
Bürgergeld für Verteidigung sind rund 52
Milliarden Euro vorgesehen auch mehr als
vergangenes Jahr damit ist knapp die
Hälfte des etas schon verplant den
drittgrößten Anteil machen fällige
Zinsen aus knapp 39 Milliarden für
weitere Ressource bleibt nicht mehr viel
sparen muss etwa die
Entwicklungshilfe mehr Geld erhalten
aber einzelne Projekte etwa der Schienen
Straßen und der soziale Wohnungsbau für
solche Investitionen gibt's insgesamt
70,5 Milliarden etwa 16 Milliarden mehr
als geplant auch für Klimaprojekte die
eigentlich aus dem geschrumpften
klimafond hätten kommmen
sollen die Neuaufstellung bzw
Einsparungen beim Haushalt produziert
anhaltende Proteste bei den Landwirten
und naturgemäß übt natürlich auch die
Opposition scharfe Kritik an den
ampelplänen bis über morgen werden die
etaläne im Bundestag weiter beraten
bevor dann am Freitag darüber abgestimmt
wird über den heutigen Schlagabtausch in
der Haushaltsdebatte berichtet Patrizia
Wiedemeier irgendwie passt der Beginn
der Sitzung zur allgemeinen schlechten
Lage im Land und zum heutigen Thema der
Gong ist kaputt das Mikro geht nicht
läuft 3 Minuten und 30 Sekunden müssen
alle warten dann läuft es wieder das
Mikro am Rednerpult und die Union nutzt
ist es gleich dazu der Regierung zu
attestieren dass es eben nicht läuft
dass der Wille zum Sparen nicht
erkennbar
sei sie geben weitaus mehr als das aus
was dieses Land erwirtschaftet wir leben
massiv über die Verhältnisse ihr
Haushalt ist weit von einer
sparanstrengung oder einem Sparhaushalt
entfernt um das ganz klar zu sagen die
SPD dagegen wirft der Opposition vor in
der
haushaltsbereinigungssitzung keinen
einzigen Vorschlag gemacht zu haben
die CD CSU ist blank liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen da fehlt entweder der Mut
oder die Ideen beides ist schlecht für
Deutschland der Finanzminister nlar lobt
die Regierung selten sei ein Haushalt so
intensiv beraten worden dies sei kein
Spar sondern ein
gestaltungshaushalt diese
Bundesregierung und die sie tragende
Koalition wir investieren in Chine
Straße und digitale Netze auf
Rekordniveau all das was ich gerade an
Gestaltung beschrie
im rmen der Schuldenbremse natürlich hat
es etwas länger gedauert aber es ist
trotzdem diesem Haushalt gelungen in
unsicheren Zeiten soziale Sicherheit zu
garantieren für die AFD ist der
Haushaltsentwurf verfassungswidrig neue
Schulden würden über Sondervermögen
verschleiert es ist ein erbärmliches
Schauspiel man belastet deutsche
Landwirte und Fischer während unzählige
Milliarden für Ausland Krieg und Klima
nach wie vor verschleudert werden
esleibeneleenen schenbremse für die der
Finanzminister sich heute besonders
lobte so wir gehen nach Berlin
scharuntaler der Haushalt 24 ist ein
ziemlicher Kraftakt was bedeutet das für
die Zukunft auch weil die
Wirtschaftsaussichten ja wirklich nicht
rosig sind das bedeutet wahrscheinlich
dass die Einigung auf den Haushalt 2025
mindestens genauso anstrengend wenn
nicht sogar noch anstrengender wird als
die Einigung auf den jetzigen Haushalt
denn die Grundvoraussetzungen haben sich
nicht wirklich verbessert man kann salop
sagen die Wünsche sind groß das Geld ist
knapp und die schwächelnde Wirtschaft
bringt dann auch nicht mehr Geld in die
Staatskassen ganz im Gegenteil ähm es
ist ja bekannt geworden dass es aus der
Wirtschaft einen Brandbrief an Olaf
Scholz gab in dem unter anderem
Steuersenkungen gefordert wurden um die
Wirtschaft anzukurbeln das würde dann
noch weniger Geld bedeuten im Haushalt
und schon jetzt beziffert Christian
Lindner das Haushaltsloch für 2025 auf
einen zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag
damit steht die Ampel genau vor
derselben Frage wie vor dem nächsten
Streit nämlich sparen oder mehr Schulden
aufnehmen und da sind die Positionen
bekannt die FDP ist für
Haushaltsdisziplin und SPD und Grüne
bringen immer wieder eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse ins Spiel diesmal wird
diese Debatte stattfinden vor
anstehenden wichtigen Wahlen im Herbst
in Bundesländern und vor der vor der
kommenden Bundestagswahl im nächsten
Jahr also es wird sehr spannend sein zu
sehen wie sich da die ampelparteien
positionieren wie sehr sie sich streiten
wie sehr sie dadurch möglicherweise auch
wieder Vertrauen ähm verspielen das
könnte drohen das ist ein großes Dilemma
das wird wahrscheinlich ein doppelter
Kraftakt live aus dem ZF
Hauptstadtstudio schakunter la energy
danke schön also schwierige
Haushaltsplanungen in einer Phase in der
deutschlandswirtschaft schwächelt und
das belegen die aktuellen Quartalszahlen
des Statistischen Bundesamtes so
schrumpfte das Brutto Inlandsprodukt
also der Gesamtwert aller hergestellten
Waren und Dienstleistungen um
0,3% der schlechteste Wert eines ohnehin
ernüchternden Jahres besonders die Lage
am Bau die deutsche Wirtschaft stehe
damit am Rande einer
Rezession erst gestern kam die
Ankündigung der Gewerkschaft werdi den
öffentlichen Nahverkehr am Freitag zu
bestreiken heute folgte der nächste
Streikaufruf am Donnerstag werden die
Flughäfen in Deutschland betroffen sein
das Sicherheitspersonal soll die Arbeit
niederlegen das bedeutet dann wohl
Stillstand und einmal mehr massive
Probleme für Reisende wir fragen unsere
Wirtschafts Expertin Valerie Haller
Valerie gerade also wurde der
lockführerstreik ja beendet jetzt macht
werdi massiv Druck warum gerade jetzt na
ja das zahlreiche Streiks zusammenkommen
liegt auch daran dass gerade einige
Tarifverträge mehr oder weniger
zeitgleich auslaufen da wird jetzt an
vielen Stellen also verhandelt und die
Gewerkschaften greifen dann zum Streik
wenn Sie die Gespräche eben für
festgefahren halten der neue Kampfgeist
hat aber auch andere Gründe die
Beschäftigten sind schlichtweg sauer die
Preise sind in den vergangenen Jahren
stark gestiegen die Löhne hingegen
oftmals kaum oder nicht im gleichen Maße
hinzu kommt dass die Arbeitsbelastung
durch den Fachkräftemangel eher
gestiegen ist Beschäftigte müssen immer
wieder die Arbeit der fehlenden
Mitarbeitenden Schultern die
Gewerkschaften sagen aber auch in vielen
Branchen wird händeringend nach Personal
gesucht und auch deswegen müsse man für
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen kämpfen um
die Jobs attraktiver zu machen
Gewerkschaften und Arbeit nemer also
sind selbstbewusster geworden es könnte
ein heißes streikjahr werden vielen Dank
Valerie Haller nach Frankfurt Streiks
beim Sicherheitspersonal an Flughäfen
nach den Bahnkunden trifft es also auch
die Fluggäste und alle Infos dazu in
unserer ZF heute App an welchen
Flughäfen wird gestreikt die gesamte
Liste dazu und welche Rechte sie als
Fluggast
haben schon heute haben viele Ärztinnen
und Ärzte ihre Arbeit niedergelegt der
Marburger Bund hatte die Mediziner der
23 Unikliniken im Land zum Warnstreik
aufgerufen hunderte sind gefolgt und
kamen zur zentralen Kundgebung nach
Hannover die Gewerkschaft fordert 12,5%
mehr Lohn und faere Arbeitsbedingungen
für die knapp 20.000 Ärzte in drei
Verhandlungsrunden konnte bislang keine
Einigung mit den Ländern erzielt werden
und demonstriert wurde auch in Stuttgart
dort kamen knapp 5000 Landwirte zusammen
zum Protest gegen die Politik der
Bundesregierung in Kolonnen reisten die
Bauern aus verschiedenen Landkreisen an
und blockierten mit ihren Traktoren
teils den Verkehr wie auf der
[Applaus]
A81 auf den kanchetter Vasen forderten
sie schließlich mehr Wertschätzung und
das Aus für die geplanten Kürzungen beim
Agrardiesel das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ist das höchste
deutsche gerichthüter des Grundgesetzes
die Urteile sind grundlegend und
weitreichend und es stellt sich die
Frage ist es tatsächlich ausreichend vor
politischer Einflussnahme durch
Extremisten oder gar vor Entmachtung
geschützt in der Ampel gibt es
Überlegungen da besser nachzubessern
Dorte
Ferber wie gut ist das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in seiner
Unabhängigkeit durch das Grundgesetz
geschützt nicht so gut wenn extreme
Parteien erstarken sagt die
innenministerinutoritäre Kräfte wollen
unsere Demokratie in unseren Rechtsstaat
von innen herausschwächen und deswegen
geht es jetzt darum die Institutionen
der Demokratie wie beispielsweise unsere
Justiz zu schützen darum geht es dieser
Tage im Grundgesetz ist die Rolle des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
festgeschrieben mit einem einfachen
Gesetz aber ließe sich dessen
Zusammensetzung ändt auch könnte das
Gericht erweitert werden dann gäbe es
neue Positionen für neue Richter das
will die Ampel gerne verhindern und
überlegt für die Richterwahl z.B eine
zwei Drittel Mehrheit im Grundgesetz zu
verankern die Union ist offen aber
skeptisch es gibt bis jetzt keinen
konkreten Vorschlag der ampelvertreter
es gibt Fragmente von Vorschlägen das
ist nicht durchdacht aber klar ist wenn
man es ernst meint mit dem Thema dann
muss man es genau beleuchten und muss
sich z.B auch die Frage stellen eine
Zweidrittel Mehrheit bedeutet eine
einindrittel sperminorität für die
gestrebte Grundgesetzänderung ist die
Regierung auf die Union angewiesen die
aber hat Klärungsbedarf eine
Grundgesetzänderung wirkt Risiken eine
Richterwahl könnte etwa durch die
Stimmen einer extremen Partei blockiert
werden wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht
vor Angriffen besser geschützt werden
kann das wird in Berlin jetzt
diskutiert im Kampf gegen Korruption in
Politik und Verwaltung steht Deutschland
weiter recht gut da zu diesem Schluss
kommt ency international probleme gebe
es aber noch im Strafrecht etwa bei
Fällen von Abgeordneten Bestechung im
weltweiten Vergleich bleibt Deutschland
weiterhin auf Platz 9 vorne sind
Dänemark Finnland und Neuseeland am Ende
des Rankings liegen Krisenstaaten wie
Syrien Venezuela und
Somalia in Madrid da gerht die neue
Regierung von Ministerpräsident Sanchez
in ihre erste Krise das geplante
Amnestiegesetz für katalanische
Separatisten viel im Parlament
überraschend durch es ging einer der
Parteien für die Unabhängigkeit
Kataloniens nicht weit genug Sanchez
hatte im November mit Hilfe der
Separatisten eine Regierung gebildet und
ihnen dafür Straffreiheit zugesichert
einige ihrer Politiker sind inhaftiert
oder ins Ausland
geflohen jetzt zu einem spektakulären
Vorgang spektakulär das
Bundeskriminalamt und sächsische
Ermittler Bitcoins im Wert von 2
Milliarden Euro lag nannt haben die
höchste Bitcoin Sicherstellung die es je
in Deutschland gab Bitcoin das ist eine
kryptowährung und eines der
hauptzahlungsmittel im Darknet dem
versteckten Teil des Internets das
kriminellen häufig als Umschlagplatz
dient was hinter der Aufsehen erregenden
Aktion steckt das erzählt Anja
Schal in Sachsen haben Faher des
Landeskriminalamtes
50.000 Bitcoins sichergestellt die
kryptowährung die im Internet gehandelt
und als Tauschmittel e gesetzt wird
entspricht einem Wert von aktuell etwa 2
Milliarden Euro das Geld soll aus
Raubkopien stammen ein Deutscher und de
Pole sollen bis Mai 2013 einen illegalen
filmstreaming Service in Deutschland
betrieben haben mit etwa 900.000 Filmen
die Behörden in Sachsen kamen den
Beschuldigten bereits
2019 auf die Spur im Zuge der seitdem
dauernden Ermittlungen soll nun einer
der Männer die Bitcoins freiwillig dem
BKA übertragen haben ein Deal mit den
Behörden dazu will sich der ermittelnde
Generalstaatsanwalt nicht äußern wir
ermitteln gegen zwei Beschuldigte 40 und
37 Jahre alt wegen des Vorwurfs eines
gewerbsmäßigen Verstoßes gegen des
Urheberrechtsgesetz wegen
gewerbsmäßiger Geldwäsche und anderem e
in diesem Verfahren ist es gelungen
Mitte Januar
2024 insgesamt 50.000
Bitcoins zu sichern unterstützung
erhielten die Strafverfolgungsbehörden
in Sachsen auch von der US Bundespolizei
FBI bereits 2020 hatten die Ermittler
bei den Beschuldigten Bitcoins im Wert
von 25 Millionen Euro sichergestellt die
seinerzeit dem Freistaat saachsen zugute
kamen eine Anklage steht nun noch aus
die Verwendung der 2 Milliarden ist noch
nicht geklärt für Sachsens Staatskasse
wären sie ein warmer
Regen Spielzeug aussuchen das geht
längst über die Wunschzettel von Kindern
hinaus Spielwaren für Erwachsene sind
ein bedeutender Markt ihr Anteil am
gesamten Branchenumsatz von rund
viinhalb Milliarden Euro der wächst da
gibt es weit mehr als die
Modelleisenbahnen der Väter gerne
basteln Gesellschaftsspiele liegen
genauso im Trend wie große Modelle aus
einen fürs Wohnzimmerregal warum also
auf der Spielwarenmesse in Nürnberg das
Motto fühl den Spirit des Spielens auch
für Erwachsene Kinder gilt das zeigt uns
jetzt Brigitte
sa die Carrerabahn kommt künftig ohne
feste Führungsschiene aus künstliche
Intelligenz erfasst und überwacht den
Streckenverlauf sodass das Auto in der
Bahn bleibt auch in schnellen Kurven
gesteuert per Smartphone App das Auto
erkennt immer genau wo es ist dass wenn
ich wirklich in dem Auto sitzen würde
das Auto beschleunigt wie das echte Auto
es bremst und es fährt sich auch in der
Kurve die trendzielgruppe derzeit die
sogenannten kidals Erwachsene mit einer
Leidenschaft fürs Spielen und Sammeln
zwei von drei Deutschen über 18 Jahren
zählen dazu Gesellschaftsspiele
Kartenspiele exit Games spielen wir
kaufen wir diese größeren Lego Sets
tatsächlich auch was so Star Wars angeht
oder auch tatsächlich Harry Potter das
große Schloss hat auch meine Frau für
sich gekauft wir spielen fast jeden
zweiten Abend spielen wir eigentlich
Brettspiele der Renner modellbausets
aller Art bei LEGO kann man sogar
blumenstreue bauen beim Geschäft mit
Erwachsenen die Spielwaren für sich
selbst kaufen hoffen sie auf Umsätze in
Milliardenhöhe ist eine große
Sammelleidenschaft da das sind oft auch
Action figuren wie man das nennt oder
modelleautos Modellbahnen also das ist
eine sehr sehr große Bandbreite es gibt
hunderte neue Spiele Ideen hier auf der
Messe jedenfalls gilt das ganze Leben
ist ein
Spielplatz ja und gespielt wird auch im
dfbpokal Norbert ich wette dass auf
jeden Fall ein zweitliges den Sprung ins
Halbfinale schafft kannst du gerne aber
es wird leider niemand gegen dich Wetten
denn es sind zwei heute abend dran und
einer von zweien die sich erst vor drei
Tagen gegenüber gestanden haben wird es
dann eben schaffen mit dem feinen
Unterschied dass Tabellenführer FC stank
pauli nachher im eigenen Stadion
antreten darf gegen die Fortuna aus
Düsseldorf 2 Z1 haben die Hamburger am
Rhein gewonnen Jochen Breier am mtertor
damit tragen die Jungs vom keits ja wohl
die Favoritenrolle
oder ja also gegen diese Favoritenrolle
können sie sich nicht wehren die haben
sie sich selbst eingebrockt durch eine
fantastische Saison St Pauli führt die
zweite Liga souverän an St Pauli ist
sogar noch ungeschlagen als einzige
Mannschaft im deutschen Profifußball
nebenbeayer Leverkusen und St Pauli hat
auch in Düsseldorf wieder bewiesen wie
stabil diese Mannschaft im Moment ist
Marcel Hartel hat mal wieder getroffen
der Mann der fast immer trifft da ist er
und die Defensive die ist ohnehin in
dieser Saison ein Bollwerk ja es könnte
heute historisches geling St Pauli stand
überhaupt erst ein einziges Mal im
pokalhbfinale 2006 war das heute soll's
wieder klappen im Duell der
Zweitligisten wir melden uns um 20:15
Uhr hier aus Hamburg danke Jochen und
wir freuen uns drauf der VfL Wolfsburg
hat die Hinrunde der Fußball buundesliga
der Frauen als Tabellenführer beendet da
das schönste Tor des Abends erzielte
Nationalspielerin Marina Hegering zur
zwischenzeitlichen 2 Z ein Führung bei
der SGS Essen für die Entscheidung
sorgte anschließend Polens
auswahlspielerin Eva por Pokalsieger
Wolfsburg damit einen Punkt vor
Titelverteidiger Bayern München und 3000
Menschen haben in Oberhof die Eröffnung
der nationalen Winterspiele der Special
Olympics gefeiert strahlende Gesichter
im thüringischen Wintersport mecka das
zum dritten Mal nach 19
und 2007 das winterliche Sportfest für
Menschen mit geistiger und mehrfacher
Behinderung ausrichtet in zehn
Sportarten wie z.B schneeschuhlufen
klettern oder skialpin geht es ab morgen
um die
Medaillen immerhin da ein bisschen
Winter immerhin danke schön Norbert so
zum Schluss noch etwas absolut banales
könnte man meinen Schlüsselübergabe in
Heidelberg aber das Haus das Baufirma
und Kunde hier feiern hat's in sich
ausgespuckt vom 3D Drucker in 140
druckstunden hochgezogen und das größte
seiner Art in Europa billig war es nicht
aber architektonisch gesehen vielleicht
der Schlüssel zur Zukunft wie passend
das als Bewohner nur Computer einziehen
das Haus wird nämlich ein
Rechenzentrum so morgen erwartet uns ein
Trockner recht milder Tag mit vielen
Wolken wo sich auch häufiger die Sonne
zeigt gleich im Wetter mit Christa Orben
das heute journal in der Pokal
Halbzeitpause gegen 21:30 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka das war's von uns vielen
Dank und gerne bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend 2° wärmer als im
Mittel war der Januar 2024 und das trotz
der winterlichen und glatten zweiten und
dr Januarwoche außerdem schien so häufig
die Sonne wie seit zwei Monaten nicht
mehr mit +
44%. der Tag morgen wird aber eher grau
mit meist nur 0 bis 2 Stunden Sonne nur
im Südwesten und auch im Nordosten da
ist es mit 3 bis 5 Stunden etwas mehr
viele Wolken gibt es auch schon heute
Nacht aus denen kann es immer mal wieder
tröpfeln an den Küsten pfeift der Wind
aus westlichen Richtungen nur ganz im
Süden ist der Himmel oft noch wolkenlos
stellenweise gibt es Nebel hier sinken
die Werte dann auch noch mal auf -2°
sonst gibt es 2 bis 6° morgen steigen
die Werte an der Ostsee auf 6° am
oberrein auf recht milde 13° das
passiert hier im Südwesten mit etwas
sonnenunterstützung auch an der Ostsee
ist es ein freundlicher Tag dazwischen
gibt es viele Wolken anfangs noch etwas
Regen in den östlichen Landesteilen zum
Nachmittag und Abend kommen dann
mehrwolken aus Nordwesten der
Südwestwind frischt stürmisch auf das
sind die Vorboten einer neuen Regenfront
die uns in der Nacht und am Donnerstag
bis zum Süden hin überquert am Freitag
und am Samstag gibt's dann eher im
Norden Regen und mehr Wind beim stabilen
Temperaturniveau zwischen 5 und 13°
tschüss